I like Sandler he calls you Coney Coney
Coney I'm telling you yeah and Sandler
um he lives not too far from me and you
know in Los Angeles
people no one gets together no one no
one just goes to someone else's house
and knocks on the door because it's I
don't know but it's La you don't do it
people live next door to each other and
never talk it's so weird they have
there's a hedge there's a gate and you
push a button and you can come in but
you don't you don't hang with people
they don't they don't drop by so I've
been in my house when I've heard outside
the house Coney Coney
and it's it's Adam outside my gate
yelling and like there you know the
buses go by the Star Tours you know
right and they're like oh the Adam
Sandler's yelling Coney in the street
and then I'll open the door and the
first thing he'll say is I'm just gonna
stop by uh and I'm like well Adam come
on in you know I'm watching the the
Patriots game let's check it out and
he'll immediately say I gotta go I gotta
go you don't want me here you don't want
me here I gotta go I can't be here oh
you hate this you hate this don't you
Coney and I'll be like just relax just
take it easy I like that Sandler does
that to you Sandler was very gracious
when he came on our show he was talking
about how you taught him how to write
comedy at SNL like you showed him how to
do a proper script and all of that and
he was I could tell he really is
grateful for that and it admires your
talent he was you know when he showed up
at SNL what I remember is
that can be a grim place just because
there's so much pressure and it can be
competitive he showed up and he was the
most enthusiastic young kid
and just isn't this awesome we're here
at SNL this is the best that's and and
and Adam always says this is the buddy
this is the best so you could go to an
IHOP and get a very mediocre pancake oh
buddy this is the best and he was just
so I I drafted off of his enthusiasm and
energy
uh and a lot of us did he was just it's
all good can you believe we're here
isn't this amazing and I love that about
him